pouvoir observer les animaux au plus
près en totale immersion c'était
l'objectif du parc de thoiry lors de sa
création en 1968
cinquante ans plus tard le zoo a
inauguré sa nouvelle animation un trek
australiens avec une volière 80 oiseaux
de six espèces différentes dont qui on a
des oiseaux de type perroquet avec des
cacatoès et des perroquets et on a
d'autres oiseaux aussi qui vont être les
vannes aux soldats par exemple où les
colons mintues revers parmi les moins
farouches les loriquets arc-en-ciel
pendant l'été les visiteurs peuvent les
nourrir une première pour jade et ses
grands-parents visages de ces
magnifiques et ses plaines couleurs déjà
par les hôtes de prêcher impressionnant
déjà on est venus en voyage de noces il
ya 40 ans donc là on regarde les petits
enfants pour les plus téméraires
direction la savane et surtout les airs
le parc a installé 1500 mètres carrés de
filair rebondissant dans les arbres de
quoi prendre un peu de hauteur et voir
les animaux sous un autre angle de sa
ferrer parc c'est hyper sympa on voit
bien les animaux du bout là on a plus
beaucoup moins l'impression qu'ils sont
enfermés on l'est on les voit carrément
liberté c'est encore mieux que dans la
voiture je trouve et surtout pour les
enfants c'est un vrai bonheur ils sont
trop contents ils attendaient que ça
c'est de revient la pasionaria fin
d'aménagement et tout ça est du coup
c'est super en tout les trucs et dans ce
zoo enfin il ya toujours des trucs sur
les pleins de trucs pour les enfants et
que c'est super on découvre aussi de
nouveaux amis animaux qu'on n'a jamais
vus pendant l'été le zoo safari de
thoiry accueille les visiteurs de 10
heures à 18 heures tous les jours
chaque année 400 mille personnes
découvrent le parc